Vamos a suponer que el día de hoy Armando
tiene 18 años...
Armando tiene 18 años...
y también vamos a suponer que Diana
el día de hoy tiene solamente 2 años, es una pequeña bebé, solamente tiene 2 años.
Ahora bien, lo que me quiero preguntar en
este video es,
¿en cuantos años... en cuántos años... en cuántos años este Armando va a tener el triple de edad que Diana?
¿en cuántos años Armando tendrá tres veces
la edad de Diana... el triple de edad que Diana?
Y bueno, sería muy bueno que en este momento
pausarás el video para intentarlo por ti mismo,
porque ya viene la solución.
La solución, porque fíjate bien, lo que
nos preguntamos es,
¿en cuántos años, Armando va a tener el
triple de edad que Diana?
¿en cuántos años?
Así que vamos a definir a "y" como la cantidad
de años que nos faltan para que esto ocurra,
"y" es igual a los años en los cuales Armando
va a tener el triple de edad que Diana,
justo "y" es lo que estamos buscando, es decir,
en cuántos años Armando va a tener
el triple de edad que Diana.
Muy bien,   ¿y qué pasa en esta cantidad
de años, en "y" años?
Pues vamos a ver.
En "y" años, ¿qué es lo que va a pasar
con mis dos personajes?
En "y" años, entonces, ¿cómo van a estar
sus edades?
Bueno, pues fijémonos primero en Armando.
Armando actualmente tiene 18 años, entonces
Armando tiene 18 años
y en "y" años pues va a tener "y" años más, entonces Armando va a tener 18 más "y" años.
Entonces Armando en "y" años
va a tener 18 más "y" años,
¿y qué pasa con Diana?
Bueno, Diana actualmente tiene 2 añitos,
pero en "y" años, Diana va a tener
2 más "y" años, es decir, va a estar "y" años
más grande, Diana va a tener 2 más "y" años,
Armando 18 más "y" años y es hora de preguntarnos
pues precisamente eso, ¿qué nos preguntan?
Lo que queremos es saber "y", pero con una
cierta condición, nos dicen que estamos buscando
una "y", una cantidad de años tales que la
edad de Armando sea el triple que la edad
de Diana, es decir 18 más "y" es igual a
3 por 2 más "y".
Este 3 que está multiplicando al 2 más "y",
representa el triple de la edad de Diana pero ojo,
no en el día de hoy, sino en "y" años,
por lo tanto, me queda 18 más "y" es igual
a 3 que multiplica a 2 más "y" y lo único
que hay que hacer es solucionar esta ecuación.
¿Te das cuenta?
No nos estamos fijando qué es lo que pasa
ahorita, lo que nos estamos fijando es qué
va a pasar en "y" años y en "y" años lo
que queremos es que pase el triple y por lo
tanto voy a distribuir este 3 multiplicándolo
por todo lo que está adentro del paréntesis.
Me queda 3 por 2 = 6, más 3 por "y" = "3y",
entonces tengo la ecuación 18 más
"y" es igual a 6 más "3y".
Y a continuación lo que voy a hacer es despejar
a "y" y para resolver esta ecuación,
lo primero que voy a hacer es pasar esta "y" del otro
lado de la ecuación
y para pasarla del otro lado de la ecuación, lo que voy a hacer es restar "y"de ambos lados de la ecuación
y ¿qué me va a quedar?
Bueno, 18 más "y" menos "y", pues estas dos
se van, se cancelan, y solamente me queda
18, 18 es igual a 6 más "3y" menos "y",
"3y" menos "y" es dos veces "y".
Y bueno, ahora tengo este 6 que me estorba,
este 6 lo voy a pasar del otro lado
y para pasarlo del otro lado, voy a restar 6 de ambos
lados de la ecuación, -6 aquí del lado izquierdo
y -6 aquí del lado derecho, 18 menos 6 es 12, estos dos se van, 6 menos 6 es 0
y después me queda solamente "2y",
entonces 12 es igual a "2y".
Y ahora bien, si yo agarro y divido ambos
lados entre 2, voy a obtener el valor de "y"
que es justo lo que quiero, entre 2 y entre 2,
¿y entonces qué obtengo?
12 entre 2, es lo mismo que 6...
déjame ver si me cabe aquí...
sí me cabe aquí...
12 entre 2 es 6, estos dos se van y me queda
simple y sencillamente "y" y entonces "y" vale 6.
Es decir, que es justo lo que estoy buscando,
en 6 años voy a obtener que armando
va a tener el triple de edad que Diana que
es justo lo que yo quería,
por eso había definido a mi incógnita
como "y" y "y" vale 6 años.
¿En cuántos años este Armando va a tener
tres veces o el triple de edad que Diana?
Pues bueno, la respuesta es 6.
¿y qué va a pasar con las edades?
Sería muy bueno preguntarnos eso, pues "y"
vale 6, entonces 18 más "y",
ojo, ya nos movimos 6 años, 18 más "y" es lo mismo que
18 más 6, lo cual es 24,
entonces Armando va a tener 24 años, mientras que Diana va a tener 2 más 6,
porque "y" vale 6, es decir, 8 años.
En 6 años Armando va a tener 24 años y Diana va a tener 8 y date cuenta que 24 es el triple que 8.
Cuando pasen 6 años, Armando va a tener 24,
Diana 8 y 24 es tres veces 8...
y ya está.